[Music]
our plan included a journey across the
entire continent
from ocean to ocean that was fine but
essentially
a quite indefinite plan we had made it
up to moscow and had discussed it
ardently all the way to america
we paced scores of kilometers over the
decks of the normandy
arguing about the details of that
journey and dousing each other with
geographic nomenclature a dinner
drinking the pure but weak wine from the
sellers of the general transatlantic
company
we mattered almost senselessly
california
takes us or something equally beautiful
and enticing
but when we stepped onto american soil
everything proved not so simple
or romantic
this video is sponsored by cool of war
the online strategy game
here at voices of the past we try and
transport you back in time
and that's exactly what happens in call
of war you get the opportunity to
rewrite history
traveling back to 1939 as you fight up
to 99 other players in real time
campaigns that can take weeks to
complete
build powerful armies by combining
dozens of different unit types
the game features historically accurate
maps and units and is fully
cross-platform
use your diplomatic skills and forge
alliances with other players on both pc
and mobile devices with the same account
i've also set up a special game of call
of war for the first viewers to click
the link in the description
go to the website or app type voices of
the past into the search bar
and enter the password which is also
voices of the past
and voices of the past viewers are also
getting a special gift click on the link
below to get
13 000 gold and 1 month of premium
subscription
for free the offer is available for 30
days so click the link in the
description
choose a country and fight your way to
victory the plan
was astounding because of its simplicity
we were to arrive
in new york by an automobile and ride
ride ride
until we arrived in california
then we would turn around and ride ride
ride until we arrived in
new york it was all simple and wonderful
like an anderson fairy tale tralala
sounds the clacson true lulu sounds the
motor we ride across the prairie we
swing over mountain chains we
quench the thirst of our trusty machine
with the icy water
of the cordularus and the great pacific
sun casts its blinding brilliance on our
tanned faces
in short you can see for yourself that
we were a bit
touched in the first place taiksas is
not called taixas but texas
but that was only half the trouble
on the fifth day the decks of the
steamer were filled with suitcases and
trunks
unloaded out of the cabins the
passengers moved to the right side and
holding on to their hats
avidly peered into the horizon the shore
was not yet visible
but new york's skyscrapers were already
rising out of the water
like calm pillars of smoke an astounding
contrast this
after the vacant ocean suddenly the
largest
city in the world in the sunny smoke
dimly gleamed this steel extremities
of the 102 storied empire state building
on the left side was the small green
statue of liberty
then suddenly it was on the right side
we were being turned around
and the city turned around us finally
it stopped in its tracks impossibly huge
thunderous and quite incomprehensible as
yet
we had not informed anyone of our
impending arrival
and no one met us we waited under our
letters for the customs clerk
finally he came he was a calm and
unhurried man
he was in no way affected by us having
crossed an entire ocean in order to show
him our suitcases
he politely touched the upper layer of
our belongings and did not look any
further
when we finally freed ourselves it was
already evening
a white taxi cab with three gleaming
lanterns on its roof
looking like an old-fashioned carriage
took us to the hotel
our attempt to take a look at new york
from an automobile
failed we drove through quite dark and
dreary streets
from time to time something rumbled
hellishly under our feet or
something else thundered overhead
whenever we stopped before the traffic
lights the sides of the automobiles that
stood beside us
hid everything from view the chauffeur
turned back several times and asked
again for the address
it seemed that he was somewhat anxious
about our english
now and then he would look at us
patronizingly and his face seemed to say
never mind you won't get lost nobody
ever got lost in new york
[Music]
we liked the room but we did not pause
to explore it
hurry into the street the city the
tumult
we threw our overcoats on the couch ran
out into the narrow corridor covered
with a patterned carpet
stepped into the elevator and the
elevator clicking
softly flew down we looked at each other
significantly after all this really was
a great event
for the first time in our lives we were
about to walk
in new york
at once a slight misfortune to fellas we
thought we would walk
slowly looking around attentively in
order to study to observe to
take in and so forth but new york is
not one of those cities where people
move slowly
the people who passed us did not walk
they ran
and so we too ran from that moment on we
could not stop
we spent a whole month in new york and
throughout that time we were constantly
racing somewhere at top speed
simultaneously we acquired such a
business-like and preoccupied air
the john peerpoint morgan jr himself
might have envied us
at our rate of speed he would have
earned approximately 60 million dollars
during that month
we earned somewhat less
we stood at the most popular corner in
the states
at the corner of 42nd and broadway
the great white way as americans call
broadway
stretched before us here electricity has
been brought
down or brought up if you like to the
level of a trained
circus animal here it has been forced to
make faces
to hurdle over obstacles to wink to
dance
sedate electricity has been converted
into duroff's
trained seal
the surge of broadway carried us several
times back and forth and
flung us into a side street we walked
again through some slums and
again did not know where we were young
men and light-coloured hats crowded
around drugstores exchanging curt
phrases
their manner was exactly like that of
the young men in
warsaw who populate crackdown maya
street in warsaw a gentleman from krakow
maya is
not considered exactly god's precious
little lamb
it is sheer luck if he turns out to be
merely a thief for he might be something
much worse
than that late at night we returned to
our hotel
not yet disappointed with new york nor
elated over it
but rather disturbed by its hugeness
its wealth and its poverty
we left the hotel to lunch somewhere and
soon found ourselves on 42nd street
during our first days in new york no
matter where we were bound for
we invariably landed on 42nd street
over the large show window of a corner
store despite the
sunny morning gleamed the blue letters
cafeteria in electric lights
generally speaking new york is
remarkable because it has everything
there you can find the representatives
of any nation secure any dish
any object from an embroidered ukrainian
shirt to a chinese
stick with a bone handle in the shape of
a hand which is used for back scratching
from russian caviar and vodka to chilean
soup and italian
macaroni there are no delicacies in the
world
that new york cannot offer but for all
of it
one must pay in dollars
and we want to talk about the
preponderant majority of americans
who can pay only cents
the splendid organization of the
restaurant business seems to confirm
that
model cleanliness good quality of
produce an extensive choice of dishes a
minimum
of time lost in dining all that
is so but here is the trouble all this
beautifully prepared food
is quite tasteless colorless in taste
it is not injurious to the stomach it is
most likely even of benefit to it
but it does not present man with any
delights any gustatory satisfaction
for a long time we could not understand
why american dishes so appetizing in
appearance are so
unappealing in taste at first we thought
the americans simply do not know how to
cook
but then we learned that that alone is
not the point the crux of the matter
is in the organization itself in the
very essence of the american
economic system americans eat a
blindingly
white but utterly tasteless bread
frozen meat salty butter unripe tomatoes
and canned goods near new york we saw
waste places overgrown with weeds
forsaken plots of earth no one sowed
grain there
no one raised cattle there you see we
were told
it simply would not pay we cannot
compete here with the monopolists
from the west somewhere in chicago in
the slaughterhouses they kill cattle
and transport the meat throughout the
country
in frozen form from somewhere in
california they ship
frozen chickens and green tomatoes which
are supposed to ripen in transit
and no one dares to challenge the mighty
monopolists
to a fight sitting in a cafe we read
mccoyan's speech
which said that food in a socialist
country must be
palpatable that it must bring joy to
people
and it sounded like poetry to us
while in america the business of feeding
people as any other business is built on
this
single consideration does it pay or does
it not pay
therefore people eat frozen meat salty
butter
and unripe tomatoes
some businessman discovers that it pays
to sell chewing gum
so people are taught to chew this
cud all the while while we were there we
felt an irresistible desire
common to all soviet people to complain
and to
offer suggestions we wanted to write to
the soviet control and to the party
control and to the
central committee into pravda that there
was no one to complain to
and there is no such thing in america as
a book
of suggestions
[Music]
the american writer ernest hemingway
author of the recently published
fiesta which evoked much discussion in
soviet literary circles
happened to be in new york while we were
there his permanent home is at
key west a small town at the extreme
southern tip of florida
he proved to be a large man with
mustaches and a
peeling sunburnt nose he wore flannel
trousers a woolen vest
which did not come together on his
mighty chest and his bare feet
were in house slippers we stood together
in the middle of one of the hotel rooms
in which hemingway lived
engaged in the usual american occupation
in our hands were high and wide glasses
of high
balls whiskey mixed with water
so far as we've been able to observe
everything in america begins
with a drink we happen to talk of
florida when hemingway had once passed
to what seemed to be his favorite theme
during your automobile journey don't
fail to visit me at key west
we'll go fishing there and with his arms
he showed us the size of a fish
one can catch at key west that is like
every fisherman he's spread his arms as
far apart as he could
the fish must have been about the size
of a sperm whale
we bought a new ford at first we wanted
to buy a ford with a radio set
but we were dissuaded by a terrible
story not long ago an accident
occurred in the mountains an automobile
was smashed
wounded people lay in it for several
hours under the sound of foxtrots
broadcast by the surviving radio set
after hearing that we refused to buy a
radio
[Music]
the machine glided over the damp asphalt
of central park west
the speedometer began to register miles
we started on our long trek
the proud towers of new york were behind
us framed in stainless steel
the facets of the empire state building
shone in the morning murkiness
hovering over the gigantic city now
we were driving through a lively and
unpretentious suburb
muddy water ran over the pavement which
was lined with parallel strips
the high strung people of new york raced
in their automobiles
on their sundry errands in a red brick
house toasted sandwiches were sold
as a matter of fact all the houses here
were brick and
all were red what can one like here
what can one learn to love here
like all the large cities of the world
new york is an
appalling city here millions of people
bravely struggle for mere existence
there is too much money in this city
some people have too much while others
have too little
and it is this that casts a tragic light
on all that happens in new york
we parted from the city for two months
the roads like the roads of ancient rome
are built practically for all eternity
[Music]
among the millions of automobiles flying
from ocean to ocean we too
were a grain of dust chased by a
gasoline
storm which has been raging forever so
many years
over america a machine raced past rows
of gasoline stations each of which had
six
eight or even ten red or yellow pumps
we stopped in a small town and dined in
a drugstore
it is necessary to explain here the
nature of a small american town
and what sort of drug store it is in
which one may die in
when america's big businessmen in search
of profit directed their attention to
the drug business
they were first of all curious to find
out what pharmacists were really doing
behind their partitions what were they
grinding there with their
pestles in those thick china mortars
while frowning
importantly was it medicine well
now how many medicines are there in the
world let's say
50 100 well 120 at the most
why then prepare them in an amateur way
in drugstores
they should be produced in mass
quantities in factories
the fact that medicines began to be
prepared in factories didn't make it any
easier for the sick man
the medicines were no cheaper but the
pharmacists
lost their income that was taken over by
the drug manufacturers
to recoup their lost incomes the
outsmarted pharmacists
began to sell ice cream thirst quenching
waters
small notions toys cigarettes kitchen
utensils
in a word they went in for anything at
all
and so the present-day american
drugstore is a large
bar although the drugstore has been long
ago converted into an eating
establishment
its proprietor is nevertheless obliged
to be a pharmacist
and have a certain baggage of learning
which is insistently indispensable
while serving coffee ice cream toasted
bread and other drugstore
merchandise
[Music]
america is predominantly a country of
one story and
two-story houses the majority of the
american population
live in small cities where the
population is three
five ten fifteen thousand every small
town
wants to be new york there are new yorks
of two thousand population there are new
yorks of eighteen hundred
we even found one new york consisting of
900 inhabitants and and it was a real
city
its inhabitants walked on their broadway
their noses
high in the air the architecture of the
buildings in the principal street cannot
present the eye with
artistic delights it consists of brick
the
frankist kind of brick laid in two-story
cubes
here people make money so there is no
room for artistic embellishments
many of the rebellious writers of
america have come from the small towns
of the middle west
theirs is the revolt against sameness
against the deadly and futile quest of
the dollar
some of the towns make heroic efforts to
distinguish themselves from their
brethren
of the same type signs are hung at the
entrance to the town
quite let us say like signs over the
entrance to a store
so that the customer may know what is
being sold where
redwood city and under inverse is
written
climate best by government test
here they trade in climate the climate
may be the best
but the life is the same as in the
cities that have no
splendid climate
an automobile journey across america is
like a journey across an ocean
monotonous and magnificent whenever you
go out on deck
in the morning or in the evening in a
storm or a calm
on a monday or a tuesday you will always
find water
of which there is no end whenever you
look out the window of an automobile
there will always be an excellent smooth
road
with gasoline stations tourist houses
and billboards on the side
you saw all this yesterday than the day
before and you know that you will see
the very same thing tomorrow
and the day after and the dinner in the
state of ohio will be the same as
yesterday's when you pass through the
state of new york
it is in this consistent sameness that
the colossal dimensions
and the incalculable wealth of the
united states
are expressed before saying about
eastern america that this is a
mountainous or a desert
or a forest land one wants to say the
main thing
the most important thing about it it is
the land
of automobiles and electricity
hope you enjoyed the video just a quick
reminder that there is a special game of
call of war for you to try out
click the link in the description to
find out more and immerse yourself
in this very detailed world
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time